Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
April 13th,
2015 w you know Monday the 13th is not bad luck.
It's Friday the 13th so fucking relax.
Cause I said 13 and right before you get all like dude,
you got to rub the fucking gallic and vinegar and you left ass cheek cause the
devil lives on the left side if you're going to have a good day.
All right,
let's get down to it.
I talked a lot of shit.
Oh the fuck you.
You sent it a fence.
You know what you actually you know why I've talked to all that shit because I
wasn't watching hockey
and all I saw,
I knew the Bruins would want a couple cause I follow him on my little smart
phone there.
You know I follow the Bruins,
the Canadians in the kings,
the Bruins and the king's cause I like him and the Canadians cause I hate him.
Right.
And I just always want to know what those fucking blue blank a Douche I doing
right.
I actually,
I liked the team.
I just hate their fans.
You know,
they don't really know hockey.
They think they do and they put on loafers and they whine.
I mean,
no Canadian fan can ever say that.
They know hockey.
When you watched your fanbase Bu Patrick was out of town because he had a bad
regular season game and a,
that curse hangs over you,
which is why you won't win it again this year.
All right.
What happens?
Stop being a cocktail.
So when the reason why I talk shit,
it was cause I like everybody else saw that thing with the Bruins was selling
playoff tickets plow.
So I thought they made it.
So I just,
you know,
if was just being a Dosha and I started giving the fucking senators shit,
I didn't even know that's how bad a fan I was this year.
But uh,
but I stuck with them and I kept talking shit I hoped against hope yesterday.
Bruins tied it up,
you know,
to go into overtime and then they fucking lost.
But um,
I dunno,
it's a lot of roads fans.
Mad season was a fucking disgrace and blah,
blah,
blah.
And other fans giving me shit.
Partly it's because I talked to all that shit,
but like I don't really consider it a fucking disgrace,
you know what I mean?
We're great franchise.
Do you know we went to the plas 29 fucking years in a row and then like another
10 years in a row and then another 10 years,
something like that.
Something we've missed the playoffs like fucking three times in my life.
Big fucking deal.
Am I really gonna be sad as a Boston fan?
Do you realize in the last four years we won a Stanley Cup?
We won a world series and a super bowl.
All we need is the fucking Celtics.
Diplo,
pull their green and white acids out of the mud and the next couple of years,
and we're going to run the table again.
And this is what kills me.
We're doing this with four fucking teams.
How can we do this with four teams?
And then you look at the state in New York that has 10 fucking teams.
The state of California has like 15 fucking teams and collectively they never
have in a 10 year period run the table and one all of them.
Go ahead,
hit pause,
look it up,
look it up.
So I am fine.
Um,
I'm not as negative about the Bruins is everybody.
I think we,
you know,
we got some good young players or whatever.
The guys that won the cup maybe got a little bit old,
you know,
what are you gonna do the fuck you gonna do.
All right,
so congratulations to all you people that have given me shit.
You know,
especially centered fan.
Well,
I guess they deserve give me shit because I talk so much stuff,
but I'm just sitting there thinking my head like,
dude,
you're a fucking eighth seat.
Do you really think you're going to win a cup?
You're not.
All right.
So we'll,
we'll save a seat for you down at the golf course for when you swing by in May.
What do you think about that?
Fucking with you?
I don't give a shit at this point.
My team's out.
If it's a cook,
good luck to everybody except for the Canadians.
Good luck to the ranger fans.
You know,
you guys want one cup and 75 fucking years.
I had been nice to see you get another one,
even though you are fans in New York teams.
And that's one of my favorite fucking arguments that you've doubled down in
every sport.
You know,
it's like you're playing blackjack and every fucking hand you get dealt dealt
two aces and you still lose.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
I'm fucking wiped out man.
I stayed out last night till like,
I dunno what I had.
I had some friends come by and we went to this,
uh,
this local bar and uh,
I didn't even drink that much.
It's just that I had a four 30 pickup for a 7:00 AM flight.
And um,
I dunno,
I stayed out til like three.
I think I slept for like a fucking hour and a half.
And,
uh,
I got on the plane and I was asleep and I vaguely remember them saying we had
mechanical problems,
had fucking taxi back to the gate.
I slept through all of that and everybody let the fog of book along just going
to take,
I slept through all of it and I didn't wake up until we were over the fucking
desert,
which is perfect.
Um,
so it was actually,
it was a great flight,
but,
uh,
I got some shit to do tomorrow.
So I am recording this Sunday afternoon.
I usually have a rule that I do not record podcasts.
Um,
you know,
on days that I fly,
cause I'm usually fucking,
I dunno,
it does something to me.
I'll tell you it does something to the funny,
you know.
Um,
so anyways,
I don't have a team to root for at this point.
So you've got gotta be asking yourself,
Bill,
who the fuck are you rooting for in the playoffs?
Play off.
Who am I rooting for?
Um,
I'm not gonna waste my time voting for the room for the center.
It'd be great to see them win because they,
they'd never won.
But I'm not going to waste my time with that because,
uh,
you know,
there are fucking eighth seat.
All right.
There you go.
So that's done.
Okay.
I think it's going to come down to,
uh,
probably ranges and Canadians again.
Um,
although,
so I figured they're the favorites.
I'm going to actually,
I'm going to in the east,
I'm going to root for the capitals.
I liked the capitals.
I like Ovechkin cause he actually scores,
he's a goal scorer,
but he's not,
he's not a pussy.
Like most goals scores,
you know,
they usually got some big guy fucking skate and right behind him,
stay away from 'em stay.
We'll give him his space.
You know,
he's got a mean streak to his game.
He actually plays a physical game.
He has gold laces,
which I think is a nice little piece of flair.
I do have to say that guy.
I think that's,
you know him or tapes of my,
two of my favorite guys to watch.
Like when I bought a Vegan,
I know there's something about the way that guy plays.
He's always in the exact same spot in the offensive zone.
It's just sitting there with this stick up in the air waiting for a fucking one
time.
Um,
so I'm going to root for those guys,
especially if they wear their old school uniforms that has this,
to have the stairs on the sleeves.
I've always liked those,
so I guess I'll root for those guys and I believe in it.
Not as much as I shit on,
uh,
New York,
which I just do because it's fun.
You know,
I actually liked the giants,
believe it or not,
even though they kicked our ass twice in a Superbowl,
um,
well kicked our ass the first time.
The second time we fucking blow.
Um,
Brady,
the Welker dope.
Um,
I actually,
I am actually a range of fan,
even though it was a Bruins fan.
I shouldn't be because they,
we had a brutal,
brutal,
brutal fucking rivalry in the 70s.
Brad Park was always wine and about Bobby Orr and well,
how we got all that attention.
He was fucking jealous.
You know what I mean?
Um,
he was like the chick that wasn't quite as hot and just sat there fucking
staring daggers at the prom queen all through the 70s.
Then what's funny is he ended up being a brewing and um,
but I was,
I was too.
Um,
I was too young to remember that.
I just,
I dunno,
I always liked the ranges.
I always liked the original six teams,
um,
including the,
the actually,
you know,
got to respect the Canadians,
you know what I mean?
Even though,
you know,
fucking 12 of their cups,
they won probably playing outdoors on a frozen river.
We beat the Montreal maroons and 12 best 12 out of fucking 27 or whatever the
fuck it was back then.
Um,
that math didn't work.
I now go fuck yourself.
Um,
best 12 out of a,
what would it be?
12 out of 23.
Right?
There you go.
Cause they had all fucking day back then.
Um,
so anyways,
I don't know why I like the Kings.
I like the Black Hawks.
I like the blues.
I think I might roof for the blues because the kings of one,
one I still like to Kingsville.
Um,
I dunno.
I like a lot of teams in the west except for Vancouver.
Although Vancouver's not Vancouver anymore.
Most of those guys left.
They still got the twins and they got burrows.
That guy,
thank God for that guy.
He's the reason why the Bruins,
one fucking Vancouver was kicking our ass and all of a sudden he just started
being a Douche and it was just like,
wait a minute.
That's what we do.
You're going to bite somebody in the finger.
Come on man.
That's,
that's,
that's what the fuck you want to play dirty Jesus Christ.
That's our game.
So anyways,
um,
I have no idea.
So I think I'll actually,
I'll be watching the kings and then,
um,
I actually like,
uh,
the blues because they haven't won ever.
And um,
and that's what I'll do.
I'll probably just be written Fonda dogs,
but either way I am,
I'm always excited for the plants,
even though we didn't fucking make it.
What are you going to do?
What are you going to be a fucking baby about?
A congratulations to the senators and I look forward to sitting next to you
watching a game with you very soon as we sit there with both of our teams,
not in the playoffs.
Ooh.
Um,
all right.
So I did,
uh,
I mentioned working in Tampa and then Florida.
I was down on Miami Beach,
which is fucking and say Miami beach.
Really?
It puts Hollywood to shame as far as a beautiful women,
uh,
train wrecks,
plastic surgery,
old guys with younger women.
I mean,
it's just,
it's unbelievable.
Um,
and some of the most,
but I do have to say someone with beautiful women I've ever seen in my life.
So I did a couple of shows that the Jackie Gleason theater and uh,
there's no fucking office that they kept.
It was just like Jackie Gleason's.
I forget who the fuck told me that.
They don't,
they have obviously they just have a green room like,
Yep,
this was his grain room downstairs.
He actually had a bed and all that.
If he got a B,
worked too hard,
wink,
he would sleep here.
And uh,
you know,
so he'd be here for the next day to go to work or whatever.
But it was still,
you know,
it was awesome to perform there.
And afterwards we went to this,
uh,
this after party and um,
it was really cool.
I got to see a Chappelle cause uh,
he was performing at this theater of saint there dare I should say bunch of days
and I've got to tell you,
I was,
I like to talk to them when we were in this fucking really loud club,
you know,
playing that,
that uh,
that music that makes me feel old,
that computer generated music and there was all these fucking strobe lights and
uh,
I dunno,
it was just a bunch of shit going on.
And they had us in like this roped off area.
And it was funny cause it was like nobody in the club.
So rather than looking like this cool VIP area,
we look like we had some sort of plague
they would trying to entertain us with a horrible music,
maybe slowly kill us.
I don't know what,
but,
um,
anyways,
I want to thank everybody that,
uh,
that came out to the shows.
I had a,
I had an awesome time.
So you know what's coming up next to everybody.
Oh,
the Billy Bible belt tour.
That's the next one.
The next one.
When the fuck did we start that?
I don't even know.
Good.
It says,
somebody tell me how to get rid of this stupid updates.
UPDATES available on my computer and it says install or my option is later and
it,
my,
all I can say is trying an hour try tonight.
Remind me tomorrow.
Turn on auto update.
So it's just every fucking day I got to click on this thing.
I never update.
Itunes is the only thing I update.
I never update anything else because it just fills up your fucking computer.
It's like my computer works.
You know what I mean?
I don't know.
I don't understand what the problem is here.
Um,
I dunno.
I don't,
I never update my phone.
I still love the iPhone four s,
which at this point it's starting to fucking starting to wig out on me here a
little bit.
I'm going to have to finally give into it,
but,
uh,
I haven't heard anybody bitching about the six in a while.
So I guess,
I guess the,
uh,
the coast is clear and I can actually buy one.
I always do that always waits for people to buy the phone bitch about it,
and then they fix it and then I buy the next one.
I draft behind you.
That's what I do.
I'm like a coward in war.
I sit in the fucking foxhole in the fetal position crying as you guys go over
the wall and take it in the face.
Right.
What is this thing doing?
Why is it blinking?
Just made a noise,
right?
Am I still recording?
I think I'm recording.
I don't fucking know.
Anyways,
the Billy Bible belt tour.
All right.
It starts April 18th and Savannah,
Georgia.
April 19th.
We're in Knoxville,
Tennessee.
Um,
the 20th,
Chattanooga,
Tennessee 21st we are in,
uh,
Memphis 22nd Sri fourth.
Thank you very much everybody for uh,
helping me sell these tickets.
Why does this thing keep beeping?
Ah,
fuck.
I don't know.
I don't even know if I'm fucking recording at this point.
Maybe it was just doing it for me.
All right.
The 23rd.
We're in New Orleans.
All right.
We're in there for them.
We're there for a couple of days and then we got Huntsville,
Alabama.
Then we got all right.
I have to fucking address why this thing is fucking BP.
What is the problem?
I have battery power.
Right?
Why do you keep making that
all right.
The fucking thing was beeping because the memory was full ice.
I swear to God,
man.
I have no,
I have no instinct when it comes to,
uh,
electronics,
technology,
any of this shit.
I just,
you know,
I,
I'm a fucking idiot when it comes to this stuff.
I like,
I like old school shit.
You know,
anything pre like digital watch.
I didn't have a problem with it.
It was simple.
You put batteries in the back of it,
you know,
you fucking wound the hands of the clock.
You looked at the clock,
they were,
it was,
you just plugged it in,
right?
Isn't that what you did?
Your wound it up.
Hey it go.
I miss those.
I miss those days.
Nice and fucking simple,
you know.
Oh Billy simple town that day.
You know,
I'd like to go back to that at some point.
Jesus fucking Christ with all of this God damn shit.
This fucking new record.
It's just so many extra goddamn bells and whistles on it.
You know what's funny is they could have just came out with the exact same one
and I want to use their other one until it was dead.
This is just for these fucking nerds were like,
oh dude,
if you're hard to no one,
you know what the no one does
the same as the old one except a couple other things.
Oh,
I'm such a cunt when it comes to that stuff.
I apologize.
I apologize to lot at all about that shit.
Um,
anyways,
what the hell was I talking about?
Oh,
I think I was listing the,
uh,
the dates on the,
the upcoming tour.
I believe we cut off the 23rd.
I'm in New Orleans,
Huntsville,
Alabama,
the 26 Jackson,
Mississippi on the 27th mobile,
Alabama on the 28th Lexington,
Kentucky on the 30th and Evansville,
Indiana on the first.
And then when we go to the Kentucky Derby,
and what's great about this tour is I haven't been to any of these fucking
places and um,
so I'm going to be performing in front of a bunch of people that never seen me
before.
Some never even heard of me.
So,
uh,
you know,
it's weird.
This is kind of like when I went through Southeast Asia,
except they're doing it in my own country.
So,
uh,
it's gonna be a good time,
but I'll tell you right now,
or bill,
he's been in the fucking gym.
All right?
I've been doing the tens when I'm on the road.
That workout,
Bart,
nick showed me is what you do,
10 jumping jacks,
10 burpees,
10 sit ups,
10 push ups,
10 like alternate leg lunges and then 10 jump squats and then you do nine run
through it again.
Then you do eight run through it again.
You all the way down to one,
and then I skip rope for two or three rounds and by the end of that,
I'm fucking dead.
And I'll tell you right now,
you'd do that.
I swear to God,
you could drink a 12 pack and eat a fucking court upon it with cheese and wake
up with a flat stomach.
All right?
They get go.
That's what you need to do.
You know,
I have a buddy of mine,
oh,
I got a friend of mine,
you know,
he's a one of these fucking guys.
You know,
he's always trying to lose weight,
right?
But he does like those fad diet things.
You know,
dude,
I've cut out all sugar,
you know,
or I don't eat carbs,
not eating bread,
not eat bread,
dude,
I cut out bread all together.
It's just like,
how long is that going to last?
How can you realistically,
realistically not have a fucking sandwich?
That's,
you know what I mean?
It's like people who try to quit eating bread,
that's like me trying to quit alcohol.
It's just,
it's not going to happen.
Like,
how long can I realistically go and just remained sober and just go through
life?
You know,
at some point you,
you really,
you got to,
you have to drink.
And I'm,
I'm saying this to alcoholics too.
All right.
I think you guys are way off base with your sobriety.
Okay?
You're missing the point in life.
The point in life is every,
you know,
you don't do it every day.
You just,
every like,
you know,
like three days you get so drunk and belligerent,
you,
you heard everyone around you that you love and a,
you maybe create a legal problem for yourself.
And you know,
I know this,
this is obvious to most of my listeners,
but I just don't understand why people go to AA meetings.
Um,
no,
I'm joking.
I just fucking,
all you gotta do is you just start your day with your fucking oatmeal.
These fucking idiots man sitting there.
Dude,
I'm done with pickles.
I'm not done with anything.
Like,
I try not to eat Mcdonald's,
but I know at some point,
oh,
I know I'm going to go in there and you know what?
I'm going to go in there.
My Heart's going to be fucking racing with excitement,
knowing that I'm doing something bad and I'm going to eat it.
And second after I eat it,
I'm going to feel like shit.
I know I,
I know him,
but I'm not.
I'm,
despite that,
it's fucking delicious when it's going down.
Right.
And I know I'm going to fucking hate,
but I'd probably just every once in a while,
hey,
did you see somebody did the,
uh,
it was great.
Somebody did the final four,
like the bracket thing,
the march madness brackets with a fast food.
And I can't tell you how disappointment pointed I was that Mcdonald's got
knocked out in the first round.
I just thought it was completely disrespectful.
You know,
this is,
this is the,
they're like the rose bowl of fast food.
These are the ones who stay started at all.
Right.
Notch.
And let me look this up and I guarantee you're going to,
you're going to take it fucking personally.
March madness,
fast foods,
images.
Come on,
Bill.
We,
you're able to find it.
Were you able to make computers work for you for once in your life that Jesus is
just a bunch of fucking advertise?
Oh,
well there is.
There it is.
I found it.
Holy Shit.
I can't believe it.
All right,
visit the page.
Visit the page.
I clicked the button.
Nothing happens.
The vein in my forehead starts to pulse,
but Mcdonald's got,
Donald's gets knocked out in the first round.
Give me a fucking break.
Mcdonald's.
They're like the Duke of fast,
a fast food.
You know,
they just did.
Just going to be in it at least to the great eight.
When you say,
what's your favorite fast food.
Okay,
in and out gets fucking knocked out.
That had to have been an upset.
Right now this is birthday cake.
First Pie.
You know what?
Fuck you internet.
I'm still fucking,
why can't you just find the shit that I need and go fuck yourself.
All right,
it's over.
Whatever.
Yet again.
You know what I need to learn how to do.
I need to learn to not just fucking wing this podcast and just search for the
shit that I want first.
Have it and then riff about it instead of getting you guys excited that I'm
actually going to complete a fucking thought on here.
All right.
Tapping out of that.
Not even gracefully.
That was just a train wreck.
I just fell out of the side of a fucking moving car.
That's what just happened.
Okay.
We went around a corner,
I didn't have my seat belt on the door opened up and then that was it.
Oh,
freckles.
Right off the side.
Road rash all over the side of his big forehead.
Um,
so anyways,
I actually watched a documentary that's,
I think it was on HBO and my lovely wife recorded it on a Frank Sinatra,
this two part series.
And I gotta tell you,
man,
it changed my life.
A
okay.
One part of it,
and it's the part where he makes his second comeback.
Like,
I guess he was like the first sort of,
uh,
you know,
he was like the Justin Bieber of back then when he,
when he first did like the,
uh,
when you first started singing,
he was a crooner when all the chicks loved them and that type of stuff.
And it's funny,
all the big bands will like the fucking bands back then.
Benny Goodman and Glenn Miller and all of them.
And they're looking at like,
who the fuck is this kid?
You know,
all these girls screaming,
you know,
and uh,
and also just speaks to the quality of talent back then and musicianship that
like a guy of Frank Sinatra's talent was considered like a,
like a fucking boy band.
Um,
and granted you had all that stuff going on back then,
right.
Miles Davis,
Charlie Parker and all that type of shit,
but they had all this amazing footage and he was in the,
I think the Tommy Dorsey band.
Yeah.
And like the,
all they're doing,
they're talking about frank and I'm looking at the band and they get buddy rich
on drums.
They don't even bring it up.
It's just the level of talent.
It was just,
it was fucking unreal.
Like he really had to know how to play back then.
So what anyways,
he had basically after he dropped off,
you know,
after his crooning thing was over,
people thought he was finished.
And I think that like the whole rockstar thing,
but it was basically was basically a rock star before rock was.
Um,
you know,
there was no history of,
of anybody ever doing that.
So when he fell off,
everybody thought he was finished.
So when he made his comeback as the singer of sad songs and lament,
whatever the fuck they said,
it was considered the greatest comeback in show showbiz history.
So that wasn't the part that scared me.
What scared me was the second time,
you know,
when he was into his 50s now think the first time he fell off it was just like,
I don't know,
he's only like his 20s and he was considered older and washed up or something or
maybe like into his thirties.
It's a 20 years after that.
He has his second one and this is the one that scared me.
And they said frank was making all these choices desperately trying to remain
relevant.
And they had,
at one point he was singing with some like Motown group and they had these
really like crazy like,
like pimp suits meets like a three musketeers kind of outfit,
right?
Late sixties crazy shit.
And frank puts on one of these outfits to sing with this popular group and he's
got that big band swing pulse and they come in more with like a Motown thing.
And I was literally on the edge of the couch watching it with like my fucking
head,
my hands going like,
oh my God,
this happened to Frank Sinatra.
Like,
what the fuck is going to happen to me?
And I immediately since then have been planning some sort of,
I got to have an exit strategy out of this business.
I've joked about it before on stage saying all this business at some point is
finished with you whether you like it or not,
but you never think about it.
All you thinking about as your next project.
Um,
this business is like a fantasy.
It's not like the real world where you're like,
I'm going to do this until then and then when I'm this age,
I'm 65 I think I'm going to retire and Blah,
blah,
blah.
Like this business.
People just fucking hang around and hang around and hang around and hang around
to the point they fucking hire you.
When people like when they go on the big bring up your name,
they go,
I thought he was,
is he still alive?
Hey,
Sharon is built.
Try and find out of bill burrs still alive.
Like that'll fucking happen to me someday if I stick around too long,
so
all I could,
you know what I felt like when I was watching that?
I felt like Pauline,
that scene in Goodfellas,
all right,
when he's talking to Henry,
tell him to stay away from the drugs and he talks about some other dawn.
He goes,
you hear about so and so,
he's gonna die in jail.
All right?
Then he fucking happening to me and I was literally watching frank wearing that
suit and that's all I could do.
Think I can't say that's not going to happen.
I just hope that does not happen to me.
Um,
I just started having these fucking panic attacks and me coming out on stage on
a cruise ship with like a Walker
and people just go in to see me at that point,
just to see me like,
yeah,
you know,
he's,
come on,
he's been telling jokes for 40 years.
We've got to go see this guy and come out with their old age spots on the top of
my head,
fucking head.
The desperately trying to cover up with fucking,
I don't know what kind of makeup you've got a goddamn sander electric sander
kick in the top of my fucking head before I go out there.
MMM.
Yeah.
Fuck that.
I got to I,
and I think I know what I'm going to do.
This is what I'm going to do.
I've got to start investing money outside of this business.
So I have ink.
I need mailbox money coming in outside of this business.
So whenever they're done with me,
I can just transition.
You know what?
I think I'm gonna.
I think I'm going to become a slum
Lord.
I'm going to live this dual life where I'm going to be this smiling entertainer
on stage and I'll do benefits for diseases and underprivileged people in all
that.
And then one day I will get exposed for the monster.
I truly am.
And I'll have all these fucking,
like,
there'll be like stories about how inexplicably,
like tuberculosis is coming back.
And eventually they'll trace it back to this,
like these four awful towers of apartments that are owned by this,
uh,
this corporation.
And they're like,
well,
who is behind,
uh,
go fuck yourself ink or whatever Billy red face,
who is Billy red face?
Then I'll fucking,
they'll bust me.
That'll,
that'll be the end of it.
And I'll,
you know,
I'll,
I'll blame,
I blame the,
uh,
the astral family
out of New York and I'll just be like,
well,
I got,
I got my business model through them.
I mean,
they did the same thing and for some reason no one trashed them.
And they actually got an entire subway stop and piece of New York,
like named after him,
you know,
Astor place.
Why can't we have a Billy's place?
I'll do it in Detroit.
I'll go,
I'll go there and I'll buy up a whole block,
you know,
and then rather than redoing it,
I'll rent it out to crackheads.
Just,
you know,
I'm just,
I'm just throwing shit against the wall here.
Just,
just,
just go easy here with this,
uh,
this,
this business model.
I'll rent it out to some crack heads.
Right.
And um,
Eh,
it's a stupid idea.
They don't have money.
All right.
So I'd have to get them out of there.
Yeah,
you get crack it out of your house.
You get,
you got to go.
Uh,
you get,
you got a bright flashlight and a garden hose.
If that's what you do and you just,
you just,
and you don't have it on full blast.
You just have it on like that.
You know,
when you're,
when you're watering a dainty flower in your garden,
you'd ever do that sitting out there,
you know,
subconsciously scratching your ass.
That's basically how you do it.
Except you hold one with like a flashlight and then you just sort of your water,
you know,
water is good for you.
That's like their Kryptonite and they,
they get out of there.
You didn't treat him like house cats.
They get up on the couch.
You don't,
you just keep doing that.
So the,
the hardest part is getting the water turned back on while they're still in
there.
You know,
I don't what the fuck I'm talking about.
But anyways,
so I watched that thing and anybody see it,
it scared the shit out of me.
This whole fucking thing of getting old and not being fucking relevant and all
of that type of stuff.
And uh,
I dunno,
desperately trying to figure out where the fuck do you go,
where do you turn to?
You know what I mean?
This is why like not having kids is fucking scary cause then you know that you
can lean back on your kid's like,
well they'll take care of me,
you know,
at least they'll stick me in a fucking home or something.
I can eat apple sauce as I yell at the wall.
Am I sitting in my own fucking feces,
right?
I mean wait till it rains my old ass out the window and I wash it all out.
Jesus bill.
Wow.
You know,
whatever,
go fuck yourself.
It scared me.
I got a little scared.
So I'm thinking a,
B and a A.
I think I'm probably going to become a slum lord on the side.
So I'll let you know if,
uh,
I could find an apartment building that cost to buy.
I don't know about seven,
eight grand.
I can go down to home depot,
puts some fucking a PCP fucking pipe in a PCV pipe in whenever the fuck it's got
what called and that's what I'll do.
Okay.
That'll be a monster on the side while I smile and wave at benefits.
That is my exit strategy.
So this is my question for you guys.
You guys in the real world.
All right,
cause I'm,
I'm not even joking about how frightening that was to watch.
What,
what is,
uh,
what is your exit strategy if you have a career right now?
All right.
And if you do have children,
do you think that you have raised your children in a way that they are both
smart enough to have a career where the,
where they can't take care of you?
And secondly,
where were you nice enough to them that they don't hate your fucking guts,
that they don't give a shit,
you know,
they don't care if you're writing a fucking old folks on where you nice enough
to them that they don't you or will you not selfish enough that they picked up
on your selfish habits and they're like,
yeah,
I don't give a fuck about my dad or my mom.
You know?
That's what I'm asking you.
I'm asking the tough questions here on the motherboard of book has.
All right,
let's read some of the fucking advertising here for this week.
Um,
all right,
well I was actually supposed to read something else first for the Thursday
afternoon,
Monday morning podcast just before Friday.
Um,
you know,
that's just basically me fucking around for a half hours as opposed to the
series shit that happens on Monday.
Then we play some greatest hits from podcasts gone by.
I was wondering,
you know,
if you guys,
if there's any subjects you guys want me to talk about,
if there's an article that pissed you off,
maybe once a week I will do a,
uh,
a rant for you.
All right.
If you,
if there's something you want me to fucking go off on,
I'll try to work up some sort of passion for it.
Uh,
you can actually,
um,
send it to the,
uh,
at the mm podcast with the Hashtag a t a m m p Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast,
and just do it on like Wednesday.
Cause if you do it today,
uh,
by the time Thursday comes around,
I'm too stupid to figure out how to,
where the hell they are at that point.
Okay.
Do it if you want to,
if you'd like to send me an email to be right on the podcast
bill@themmpodcast.com.
All right.
And with that,
here's your favorite part of the podcast.
Everybody,
you get to listen to all freckles read out loud here.
Alright me undies.
Oh Shit.
Right out of the gate.
I got to sing here.
Me undies,
me undies.
No more sweaty balls.
Boodle boop,
boop.
[inaudible] Biondi is where I'm in a Horsey stall fucking shoe,
that thing and get kicked in the face.
These underwears fit every fucking race so you can wear me undies if you've got
a big Dick or little,
it doesn't matter.
Put 'em on your fucking balls.
All right,
me.
Andy's 90% that's the percent of your life,
okay.
That you're in your underwear.
Underwear.
It gets old fast.
You know that feeling and put,
putting on old saggy underwear makes you shoulders slump,
doesn't it?
Huh?
You start wondering why you're married.
The person sitting across from the table,
right?
They bite into that English muffin.
You,
you start thinking about killing yourself.
You need to know the feeling of great fitting underwear that is two times softer
than cotton.
You need to know about me on [inaudible] dot com [inaudible] is the most
comfortable underwear you will ever wear and it's an insane how good they make
you feel.
They fit perfectly.
They know right up on you.
They literally pull moisture Ross away from your skin so you stay cool.
All right.
They have cool styles for both men and the fucking lace and they all look great.
Check out the photos for yourself.
You pervert@meundies.com this quality would typically retail for two times the
me undies price.
No retail middlemen means more savings for you here.
I will make it easy for you.
Go to [inaudible] Dot com slash burn get 20% off your first order and free
shipping.
Save even more.
When you buy a pack of them,
they you're going to be happy with them or your first pair is free.
All right,
next draft,
kings.com everybody.
You know what?
One of my friends from back home actually use this and was raving about it,
saying how much fun he was having.
So there you go.
There's a little endorsement sort of from me via front draft kings.
The wait is finally over.
Baseball season is
hey@lastandtheexcitementcontinuesallseasonlongatdraftkings.com the official
daily fantasy partner of major league baseball.
Mlb is involved in this and they won't let fucking Pete rose in the hall of
fame.
Ah,
you fucking hypocrites.
Daily fantasy means no season long commitments,
just instant cash,
instant gratification for you right there sitting at your computer.
Why wait until the end of the season to claim victory when you can win huge cash
every day at draft kings,
it's like a brand new season.
Every fucking time you play,
just select two pitchers and eight position players.
But you gotta stay under the salary cap now and you could be on your way to an
enormous pay day.
Last year,
Peter from Colorado,
one a million duck bucks@draftkings.com in one day just playing baseball.
Another guy lost his marriage and his entire family.
It's all how you decide to gamble.
Hundreds of thousands of fantasy sports fans just like you already cashed in a
draft kings.com now it's your term during call to Action Herrick to draft
kings.com now and enter the Promo code defense to play for free.
You could win part of the $300 million in prizes being awarded this season for
$300 million.
Jesus Christ.
How many people are playing use Promo code defense for free entry
now@draftkings.com draftkings.com that's draft kings.com.
I got to give it up to these guys.
They found a way to make the dog days of baseball.
You know,
they always say the dog days of summer.
It's the dog days of baseball after,
after fucking April.
You know what I mean?
You're already Jones and for football.
What a great way to watch baseball.
You know,
throwing your mortgage on the line when the cubs are playing the candles.
Um,
no,
actually I don't know.
Every time I read that I start thinking that be kind of fun to put together a
team.
Stay under the salary cap.
Oh God.
Am I gonna be one those guys that fucking police fantasy football.
All right,
let's read one.
Well,
I mean,
what do I got here?
All right,
we'll read one more dollar shave club.
Everybody Dollar Shave Club.
Oh my God,
man.
I see.
Have you heard about dollar shave club?
Oh,
you can shave your twat and there's no razor bumps.
You've heard me talking about dollar shave club.com.
The company that delivers amazing razors for a few bucks.
I know a razor that costs a few bucks.
Delivering a great shame seems too good to be true,
right?
But you really have to try the razors,
the dollar shave club.com raisers.
We'll give you the most amazing shave that you've had in years.
Don't pay triple the price when you can get a fantastic shave delivered for just
a couple of bucks.
Um,
you have to be an idiot to keep overpaying.
I love,
I always fuck up reading that sentence.
Why don't I go?
You have to be an idiot and I can't even read this sentence.
I am a massive celebrity and I'm constantly getting my picture taken by a
Weirdos in bars or I'm on some TV show in a hut in high definition.
I can't be seen with nicks and cuts all over my beautiful face.
I have to shave what they high quality razor.
Okay?
Don't be fooled by the price.
These races are legit and you will never go back.
All right.
Plus they've got,
oh my God,
they've got Dr Carver's easy shave.
It's phenomenal.
If you're still using old fashioned shave foam,
you're a loser and I feel bad for you.
Try Dollar Shave club.com/burr to get started.
You'll wish you had started sooner.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr dollar shave club.com/burr.
I really want to go to the fucking thing where whoever came up with that.
You have to say it three times or they don't hear it,
right?
Okay.
That's go fuck yourself.
Dot.
Or go fuck yourself.
Or go fuck yourself.org.
Um,
all right,
let's read some content here for this week.
Um,
what do we got here?
All right,
the Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast.
Okay.
Bill,
in case the rest of the morons who listen to your podcast having extended a
thank you yet.
Let me do so on behalf of them for the Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast that comes in just before Friday there.
Uh,
I love the music between the old clips.
Especially last weeks my wife and I were listening on the way to work and she
pointed out that you sound different on Thursdays.
Monday you come out of the gate and by Thursday you seem more at peace.
It's probably too early to claim a pattern,
but we'll see.
Anyways,
thank you again.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
Can women ever just fucking not be trying to figure what figure you out the
fucking weird.
Okay,
sorry.
I needed a drink there.
You know,
he seems more,
I liked the Thursday bill,
like just like,
and you know what?
And they always act like what they're trying to do is to make your life better
and all she's doing,
she's like,
they're constantly gaining like a reconnaissance,
like information.
You know what I mean?
Cause generally speaking,
let's shoot,
you're dating one of those UFC chicks,
you know what I mean?
They can't beat the shit out of you.
So they got to go cerebral.
So they are constantly on some sort of surveillance mission,
even on a guy that isn't in their fucking lives.
Just weirded me out that she's listening to it at that level.
And you know,
it's funny,
she just does it naturally.
Who the fuck else would be thinking that he seems more um,
melancholy on Wednesdays,
but on Saturdays there's a light.
There's a light at the end of the tunnel.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Maybe because Monday's I'm flying back from somewhere and I'm hung over.
How about that?
Maybe that's what it is,
but I'll tell you right now,
I'm never more at peace.
Um,
I'm actually happy so we would ever think that they heard that in my voice.
All right,
I'm going to read this one.
I'm going to read it in my,
I guess my Thursday.
Let me try to get myself more at peace here.
Need advice.
Hey Billy Bitch tits.
I need your help.
My girlfriend of three years has been acting really strangely.
Later things were fine up until two months ago.
We were banging in,
hanging all the time without,
I can't do this.
We were banging in hanging.
Well,
Jesus,
you high fiving while you were fucking too all the time.
I'm going to come up top
up top Brophy.
Jesus.
That should I just fucking switch a roo there?
Huh?
Um,
we were banging and hanging all the time without any problems at all except for
the odd fight over which restaurant to go to.
Life was pretty sweet anyways,
lately she's never been available between 7:00 PM and 10:00 PM.
And when I do reach her after 10:00 PM,
she's really grumpy,
doesn't want to talk to me,
she tells me it's not me and not to worry,
it'll be better soon.
But she's been like this for the last two months and there's no end in sight.
She's also keeps canceling our plans at the last minute saying she's not feeling
up to going out.
She's never act like this before.
And we've known each other for seven years.
Oh Jesus.
The seven year itch there.
Um,
anyways,
yesterday was the breaking point.
I called around 9:30 PM and she told me to go fuck myself and hung up on me.
I called it back 45 minutes later and I'll be honest,
I was crying a little.
Ah,
God,
she's in your heart now.
Do it while seven years.
He's going to be a,
what was different was that this time she was crying too when she said she was
really sorry and that the last two months,
oh fuck you.
I'm not even going to read that.
Come on man.
Hey Andrew.
Quit sending me the fucking troll once.
All right.
Election.
Uh,
I'm on,
I got to read it because it was funny,
but I mean,
I don't want to turn all of these questions into everything and wow.
Wow.
It was just a joke.
Cause then I don't have anything to fucking tie.
There was,
she had been watching the Bruins and blah,
blah,
blah.
Basically,
if that was a real one,
she would have been crying the entire season.
Uh,
yeah.
Don't send me these things because this is what helps me talk for a fucking half
hour.
If,
if every one of these is going to be like,
oh,
I fucking trolls you IEPs.
That bap,
bap,
you know.
Anyways,
election dear Capitol Hill.
Bill,
can we get your thoughts on the 2016 election?
Hillary,
Ron,
Paul or rand Paul.
Ted Cruz,
uh,
thoughts on any of them or what direction you think this country is going in?
Um,
I think Hillary's got a great shot because she's a woman and there'll be a big
pressure to not say she stinks because you'll get branded as a sexist.
Um,
I'm sick of the Clinton family,
the Busch family.
I,
I just,
I need a fresh face to be lying to me.
That's the one thing I've loved about Obama over the last eight years at least.
It was a different face,
you know,
just shoveling a bunch of shit at me as opposed to just fucking,
I mean,
can we just get out of the fucking Bush,
Clinton,
Bush,
Clinton.
I don't want to do that.
You know,
I really don't.
And also when a woman becomes president,
it's going to,
it's going to crush me to watch how excited women are going to be as if it's
going to make a bit of fucking difference.
And I don't mean that in some hateful way towards women.
I just can't stand people who fucking honestly look at the presidential office
as if that person can,
can do anything.
You know,
this is going to get,
this is going to get fucking dark here.
I think it's all bullshit.
When you look at what fucking
politicians make,
it's pathetic.
It's pathetic.
What?
They make 400 grand to be president.
He get 200 something grand to be a God damn senator.
All right?
And all of those offices costs millions and millions and millions and millions
of fucking dollars to get.
So you have to go to all these other fucking guys and then you all,
all of them favor.
So you're bought and paid for before you even get into the fucking office.
And then what happens is afterwards,
somehow like,
I like some ridiculous,
like 65 to 70% of of senators are multimillionaires.
It's like,
how the fuck did you do that if you just made a couple of hundred grand a year
because you're going to get whacked and half and taxes.
You know what I mean?
I just think the whole fucking thing is corrupt.
And um,
look at Obama.
The first African American president,
you would think that they would be there.
That should have been the most liberal fucking guy ever.
And he wasn't.
It was just,
to me,
it was just more of the same,
more of the fucking same,
more of the lead.
People are going to get us more of that shit and just getting everybody to hate
everybody all around the fucking world.
It's just been all of that same exact shit.
And I don't think,
you know any of those guys.
I don't know if
who's the,
who's the woman that I do like is the one who's fucking actually calling out the
banks and say we need to break up the monopoly.
That's the one that I like out of everybody that I've heard talked,
she's the one that I am actually like,
wow,
she's actually saying something,
you know.
Um,
but I mean if she actually tried to do that,
she would get whacked and I totally believe that she would,
she get,
I don't know that they even have to fucking whack it now.
They can just,
they'll just destroy you if I don't know that,
go through your emails and they'll kill you that way.
But,
uh,
that's,
that's what I,
that's what I feel and all that.
I think it's a,
I think it's hopeless and um,
yeah,
we're going to fuck it all up in the world at some point will be unlivable
because it'd be so polluted and overpopulated and then we'll basically,
I don't know,
some will happen a volcano or merciful asteroid and uh,
that's,
those are my beliefs.
So they go,
hey,
maybe that woman was right that I am more at peace and hopefully on Thursday re
ask me that on Thursday and I'll be like,
you know what?
I think Hillary is the wonderful,
that'd be so great for women everywhere and men.
All right,
thoughts on Pete rose?
Hey Bill,
big fan.
I know you're very passionate about sports.
Was curious where you stood on Pete rose with all star game in Cincinnati this
year.
Now if ever would be the time to get for him to get reinstated.
Now that you've got podcast twice a week,
thought you might have time to rant about Pete rose sometime.
Check out the link below.
If you have a minute song.
I wrote,
put rose in the hall of fame.
Love you brother.
Um,
I dunno,
you know,
I think when you fuck up like he did,
I mean that's the number one thing you're not supposed to do.
You're not supposed to a gamble on baseball because that fucks with the,
the,
uh,
the integrity of the game beyond like even like steroids.
MMM.
Cause then you're literally like trying to lose a game possibly,
which at least with steroids,
you're trying to fucking win.
At least you're trying to fucking win.
And I know he says,
I never bet against my team,
but I mean,
I dunno if anybody knows a fucking degenerate gambler.
I mean eventually,
you know,
you get yourself into situations and you need that one big score and there's 162
games.
Hey,
why don't I bring that guy up from AAA and put them on the mouth and see what
happens.
Um,
at the last second,
of course,
um,
I wouldn't mind if they put them in at this point.
I feel like he paid the price,
but I had no sympathy for the guy,
uh,
you know,
for the first,
like 20 years of the shit.
But,
um,
at this point he's an old man,
just put them in there.
I mean,
the guy,
he was so great for baseball and it's just unfortunate that he had that problem.
And,
um,
I think he paid the price.
I'd let them back in.
They could go.
Huh?
There's a little Thursday attitude for you.
Wasn't that nice?
Oh,
it was that a little tear in my eye.
Um,
all right.
Where are we going here?
A dare devil.
Jesus Christ.
Daredevil.
Dear wonder bill.
You don't strike me as much of a comic book Fan.
Yeah,
I liked him when I was a little kid.
Oh boy.
Do you think aqua man could beat electric?
Man?
What about the gas burner?
Um,
but you should really check out the new daredevils show on Netflix.
The fighting is great.
Uh,
he gets his ass kicked,
which adds to the reality of one guy walking into a room and facing seven
others.
Vincent D'onofrio.
All right.
I'm already in Rezai.
[inaudible] Dawson.
I'll write,
I'm in one of the hot chicks from true blood is in it.
It's dark as hell.
Please report back with a review.
Uh,
are you caught up on the following?
I never saw the following.
Um,
I'm trying to find where the fuck I can watch the pilots of better call Saul.
They don't have it as far as I can tell up on AMC.
If anybody can find me that,
and like the first two episodes I have the rest of season taped episode three
through the finale.
I have to do that first and then I'm going to go to dare devil.
I really want to get into Lord of the rings,
but I just hate fucking period pieces with the fucking,
I just hate the clothes,
you know what I mean?
They're walking around and those castles with no central heating and nobody has
ever shivering.
I just can't get into it.
Um,
all right.
What does the following,
what is the fallen?
I mean,
what the fuck is that that does that,
that they'd better not be aware of Zombie of a vampire thing.
If I had to guess the following.
Is that about somebody who starts a church?
Is that what it is?
Come on old computer you can do it
is that long.
It takes my fucking God damn neighborhood because we won't have one of those
fake Internet trees cause it will muscle the integrity of the aesthetics.
The following,
the following,
uh,
I watched the most current episode on Hulu,
the following TV series,
a brilliant and charismatic yets psychotic serial killer communicates with other
active serial killers.
How the fuck have I not been watching this?
This is tremendous.
And advocates a cult of believers following his every command.
All right.
So what they did was they took the Charlie Manson thing and I think they added a
little,
a little extra thing to what he used to have to stand in front of him.
Now these guys can do whatever the fuck he wants.
He all right.
I'm in.
Yeah.
So can I do,
there's never been another time in the history of television where there's been
this many unbelievable shows to watch.
Like it's insane.
I don't get why a TV shows so fucking great.
And it's so hard to find a good movie now.
Okay.
You know,
I mean,
people steal TV shows too.
I'm starting to think,
movies don't have an excuse anymore.
Everything doesn't have to be a fucking hundred million dollar.
Uh,
okay.
I don't know.
You don't actually did see a great movie.
I don't know if I brought this up at anybody.
See a wild tales is the name of it.
It was,
um,
a movie made by some director out of Argentina.
It's fucking phenomenal.
It's like six back to back stories.
Um,
almost,
it's kind of seems like,
like a format,
like a Tarantino type of thing that he would do,
but they're unrelated.
But there's a I a overall theme of this really dark comedy,
a revenge in that type of stuff.
And it's,
um,
me and Nina saw it the other day.
We absolutely fucking loved it.
Um,
called wild tales.
definitely.
Definitely check it out,
man.
It was,
it was,
um,
I don't know.
I'll tell you it was a great movie,
you know.
All right.
A great book.
Bill.
I am reading this book,
um,
called men on strike.
Why or why men are boycotting marriage,
fatherhood and the American dream and why it matters.
Oh,
Jesus.
Dude,
why would you abandon all of that?
It is,
it is a very in depth look at the lack of paternal rights and laws in this
country.
I've been talking to a lot of younger guys in the military about it,
so they don't get caught up.
Um,
yeah.
But what they should have is on the back end of that,
like,
okay,
so if you never gonna get married and you never going to become a dad and have
the picket fence and all that,
what you need to do is you need to go hang out with some old playboys who are in
their fifties,
early sixties,
and you will see a sadness in their eyes that you do not want your soul.
I will tell you that because as much,
as much as I go off and make fun of women and everything,
you know,
I am 10 times harder to live with,
so I mean they're,
they're tortured by us too,
but I really can tell you that going solo is not the way.
Um,
for most people I would think.
I mean some people are just wired that way.
I mean,
I have a little bit of that.
Like I am a big time,
big time loner.
I got this weird thing where I won't shut the fuck up when I'm with my friends,
but like anytime we have like company and Shit,
I swear to God,
like I,
I can only do it for like eight to 10 minutes and all of a sudden I'm,
I'm,
I just have to get up and walk out and be by myself,
sit outside in the porch just staring at a tree.
It's really fucking weird.
Um,
unless maybe I'm just selfish and less the subject is something that I'm
interested in what everybody's talking about.
I got to whisper this shift.
My wife has this,
she's going to be pissed,
a great bill and then post it like she's not going to find out about it.
Um,
no,
I just,
my brain just shuts down.
That's basically what happens.
And it's something that he has said about me a long time ago.
She goes,
you've just,
if you don't give a fuck about something,
you just stop listening.
And it's really annoying.
And it's like,
ah.
All right.
Well,
I thought it was listening to my inner voice,
you know?
I mean,
what,
what the 40 I am.
I am.
I'm always amazed at people that are,
that have really good social graces,
you know what I mean?
They come in,
they know how to throw a party,
make sure everybody's comfortable,
they notice that somebody's drink is empty and all of that.
I just find this like,
hey,
how you doing?
All right.
Boom.
Is over there.
See you later.
You know,
I come more with that vibe.
I'm not gonna tell you right now.
The second I'm done uploading this fucking thing like,
uh,
I am,
I don't know.
I'm just going to go sit out on my porch staring at a tree thinking nothing.
I think I'm probably slowly losing my fucking mind.
Who knows?
Um,
all right.
Let me read the last mercifully read the last couple of these live reads.
Clicking on this,
scrolling
down.
Legals are these guys.
The copy is always so fucking intense.
All right.
Legal Zone.
If you're thinking about starting a business,
now's the best time to do it.
It's national starch,
your business month,
every month@legalzoom.com.
It's never been easier to start your business.
You're building,
uh,
never been easier to start building your future.
Legal Zoom provides the support you need for more than 10 years.
They've helped millions of business owners just like you.
If you need advice for your business,
no problem.
Legal Zooms,
not a law firm,
but they've built a network of trusted attorneys to provide the guidance you
need for your specific situation.
Here's the best pot during national starch,
your business month.
Legal Zoom is offering an attorney consultation.
Woo for only 50 bucks.
If you're unsure about the best way to start or if you've already run a business
and need some advice,
this offer is for you.
Can they help me figure out how to become a slum lord?
I'm get legal advice for your business with no further obligations for a low one
time costs.
Go to legal zoom.com today to find out more attorney consultations are provided
by independent attorneys available in most states.
Get the legal help you need for your business@legalzoom.com and enter
[inaudible] in the referral box to save even more legalzoom.com Promo Code burr
legal help is here.
All right,
the last one are old friends,
stamps.com one of the best recommendations I make to small businesses is to use
stamps.com stamps.com makes mailing and shipping so convenient and saves you
time and money.
Buy and print official US postage right from your computer.
Once you try it,
you won't go back to making time consuming trips to the post office to get you
started.
stamps.com has special offers from as a special offer.
For my listeners,
just use my last name,
birth to get a no risk trial.
So there's nothing to lose plus $110 bonus offer and includes a digital scale
that calculates the exact postage for your letter and packages.
No guesswork and up to $55 free postage.
stamps.com is easy to use.
Print postage for your letters or packages right from your desk.
Then just hand them to your mailman.
Over 500,000 small businesses are using stamps.com and guess what?
You should too.
I use stamps.com to send out all my believe the Bible Belt fucking toward
posters
for the tour that's coming up to Thursday.
Billy the Bible Bowl,
no Billy button,
the Billy Bible belt tour.
I can't even say it and I'm a moron if I can figure out how to use their scale
and all that shit.
So can you remember for that my,
remember my special offer.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburpeeyouarearethatstamps.com enter burr.
I actually have to confess to stamps.com I went to the post office the other
day.
Yeah.
You know what it was?
Um,
I just wanted some colorful stamps.
Every once in a while,
you know,
I want some nice stamps and I got these,
I get these,
I stood in line and it was a shit show and it was every reason why I don't like
going down there.
And I came up in line and of course I was the next in line and then the fucking
person hit puts the next window sign there.
It really should just say go fuck yourself.
And then pointed different directions.
So I'd get battle of New Orleans,
the war of 1812 stamps,
which I think are pretty cool.
And then I got these crazy circus ones and I hate the circus.
You got a bunch of scary clowns.
There's a tiger and an elephant,
which,
you know,
were abused.
Um,
I know why.
I'm telling you this and then I got a bunch that had flowers on them.
They usually have some cool shit that we have like race cars and shit like that.
You know what I mean?
What do you fucking eight years old?
Well,
Hey,
you know what?
I'm a big kid.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I enjoy that type of stuff.
Anyways.
Um,
this is the,
this is the deal for this week,
man.
The biggest thing in my life here is this bus tour coming up and I got to tell
you,
uh,
I'm so fucking excited to be going to these cities because I've never been there
and I'm going to be in front of a bunch of people that I haven't had the
opportunity to,
to perform in front of and their vibe.
I'm never going to,
it's going to be a new experience.
You know,
when you get out of your comfort zone and there's going to be a lot of shit that
I'm going to say that they're going to take maybe in a different way,
which will cause other things to happen.
It's going to be and it's going to be so much fun and I'm going to not
understand what they're saying.
Sometimes the other way around.
It's the fucking greatest.
And,
uh,
it's going to be me,
Paul Versey and Jason Law head and,
uh,
Eh,
I can't wait.
So please,
if you're in the area,
please come out and tell your friends about it and,
uh,
we'll give you a great show.
And then with that,
that is the podcast for this week.
So once again,
congratulations to the Senate as you guys deserve that you were the better
fucking team.
Congratulations to the penguins,
the fucking penguins,
um,
rangers,
even the Canadians.
Congratulations all you guys hope you guys,
whatever.
I'm not going to be a cunt about this,
so,
right.
Good luck to all of you.
I hope all your dreams come true even though it will only happen for one fan
base.
Um,
so I'm rooting for the capitals and uh,
I've kind of become a kings fan.
It got to admit it,
but,
uh,
I will also be rooting for the blues,
um,
just because they haven't won it.
I don't even know where the predators in it.
A roof for something like that.
Then the jets,
they have a one it,
I dunno who gives a fuck this kind of a freedom for your team not being in it.
Then he,
you know,
you don't,
you can stop ruining.
Oh,
when people I root against,
I will always move against the Canadians.
It's my job as a Bruins fan.
That's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.